don't throw yourself it's going slowly
you don't have to protect yourself okay
follow the rules of the Kami let's go
everything counts don't excuse yourself
on anything
that's not severe naked
incineration thinking not just
individually but in terms of the quality
of the doctor so a lot of times when
you're learning and Kimmy you're not
realizing that you're still being
determined by your fear and you want the
slope his way to stop doing that so some
of the things for example that I'm
seeing do be okay so watch nothing he
did stop me from from maybe that I'll
show you sir
he was she like this what I got same
thing you just did alright so his job is
to figure out how to get me to do that
music he didn't get it so he goes to the
next counter and then these training
cheat was do you get that so I don't
throw I don't throw myself in your penny
and you have the weirdest concept where
you think you're making yourself your
job is to make yourself throw a bowl for
the key one that you're predicting then
that's not it
okay so their their job is to just
follow the rules of mckimie so he has to
keep his grip he asked to keep you strip
that's the rule okay if I don't taste
enough ballast you see where he goes
that's where he has to go so I have to
do something else
so you're out
you're just like your fear and there is
Kimmy you think you're doing good but
you just practicing evil and peer driven
life is evil
don't do it try something else when I
say every throw counts useless that's
exactly what I think
so let's say I go like this and I'm
doing this stuff is he joking now no
he's not I'm not doing it
okay he can keep moving and do whatever
he wants you see see how that was in
space in there okay so you know oh
that's he ah no we're not doing that
okay let's go
[Music]
they're either gonna tap or they're
going to be thrown out go take the knee
go hit the shoulder down
[Music]
maybe I take too many days off
stop trying for that basement you don't
know it you did not train enough to know
it keep going just do the key you
[Music]
get to your backside
fix your back foot oh no I threw you
with that back foot unless your
charlatan
try to not let the arm curl around you
[Music]
you go to the ground and escape a stomp
you can't just get kissed a guy come in
I got you
you don't want that mindset let's go
stop sitting down like you actually give
a about your teacher this
train
make it count there's that put again
[Music]
right you mother and my sister it's not
like Cheetos judy was that you're not
trying to be spontaneous you can be
spontaneous with the harder
I don't want to see how you're the
basketball star dribbling spontaneously
that's not training right there the back
break fall eg1 that should not happen
where she's standing still am i pushing
about blackberry ball shift come forward
not to get her to go see our 70 stomach
full it's the same people so I can't go
like this
her 7 keeps coming forward right make
them go back
Oh at this rate your power already
different I will have it
that's why though
mechanically but I don't start freaking
I want to learn what the body does so at
this speed try to step out
you see same thing here
no I buy it through mechanically wool
[Music]
now
that you guys aren't doing it go if I
throw him down and I go down on them
this is it
that's the drainage like yourself
you're going backwards got to enter you
can regain your balance you should
regain it it's mostly the moment
mechanically you don't have any moment
I thought I could just sign up at the
skill would come in when I signed the
blind there hit that back foot right
[Music]
not backing up
good eye on me
take them out take them out punch her in
the face
watch my energy output is slow training
I should be blending and neutralizing
there becomes like right every
contention point don't need my muscle
I'm not yet
okay
[Music]
I
that's why you can't rely you're doing
too much too much this to get too much
this noggin there's no who way to your
art don't it's warm have symmetry in
your body not a tranquilizer dart and
the other side
[Music]
lower the hand lower the head bad form
she left the hand he won he not get sick
on in GU you see that place you're
making my you get it if if you use the
Kazushi over here both then you should
do this don't do anything see if you
have to turn see you got Oh hear
comments on man please
that's it hope you exercise at the end
so I think use it and now you wanna
bhagavata Fayed
do you see but I can't go do it folks
you all technique at the end of the two
on the application go alive you can't
would have exposed it to up right here
in the stomach keep moving the end I got
you there's little weight on your tummy
go uncomfortability is not a pain
throw the other way he's crossed the
center line
[Music]
don't follow them down terrible posture
don't refer to other people lower taller
people to your height
[Music]
keep connected through centers on you
man oh reactors these parts s you can
always break away you don't know where a
person with the weapon pulls it out and
kills you guessing you've fallen again
[Music]
countering your technique you think that
one song and a soft if you have to
address that that long if you see you
see you should feel it
um if you control the controller
[Music]
and you will about being safe because
you lie pulling on this technique right
there
do you feel your lack of control okay
you got me you see it but this is off
you can really want it
you have to feel that because the
hostile person is gonna skate this is
not gonna go down a bit do you think is
the Virginia the scare you kids gonna do
it every time and it's the opportunity
to do a hen kalasa
so they're countering you you counter
the counter but you have to feel it and
recognize it if you're okay hey how
about reconciling out fear
right and you both meet
hmm let's stand still I'm gonna throw
this guy who's got a foot height on me
75 pounds that sounds like Aikido
remember that's not a pin gingy you
wanna go go I'm not gonna load there it
is again
I won't lower the Hat and the head stays
up that was the counter converging it's
your task not to do it does say things
like that right there
did your Jackson how to counter that
counter that's better
what's happening is you're disengaging
your Center right and then that's not
training you need that engage Center and
when you have a social violence and
aggression you will have a unified map
you get it you don't leave your Center
out of that kind of aggression so or
you're not training our noggins but for
the feel the subtlety of this and the
counter but you're not getting better as
you kick you just not understanding what
you're seeing is really what you see is
is to say me go you don't want to lose
you don't want to lose and so you're not
I'm going to disengage myself from the
technique do you get that do you guys
understand that so fortunately for the
questions no one does that
but in training you can do it when it's
slow so you don't you really need that
skill but you should have that kind of
sensitivity to feel the technique now
being altered and you should now go do
something else under slow G while the
rules
got it but if you can't that's not what
we meant by don't throw
self that's not what we meant okay
we're not trying to win this is you
can't go that's right ready to make them
pay for it she's doing it too
Oh always pick hit the out of
people
before you pick pinning them
[Music]
you're just rustling rat that's a that's
an insult to wrestling not wrestling
you're just doing crap so if you do a
projection versus the fixated throw that
only fondant will work there should be a
projection in your p1 anyway there's not
a fixated illusion throw okay
you're leaving it now and you're just
going to do a leveraged zone should be
an internal projection try it again
[Music]
project trap again
don't get your Virginia
[Music]
finish it get the triangle
you
[Music]